[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrass
tyson your personal astrophysicist
and i'm here in studio with chuck knight
sitting across from me
yes chuck nice comedian how you doing
man i'm doing very well
you got gigs lately yeah i don't want to
be your only gig you know i mean you
guys don't know i'm you know
i still do uh my little tv shows that i
do
and yeah they bring you on a comment on
stuff yeah you know uh
the latest one you should check it out
if you can on true tv called how to be a
grown-up
okay why they asked me to be on it i'll
never know
um and uh and i still do stand up
okay you know do stand up you know i
don't think i've ever seen you do stand
up
oh really you got to come sometimes no
let me restate that
i don't think i've ever been invited to
see you
[Laughter]
snap from what i hear i'm very funny
that's what people tell me all the time
you know so so we've got another cosmic
queries edition of star talk
yes this is like fans people like cosmic
queries
you know i'd rather you know i prefer to
be like interviewing guests and stuff
you know oh well thanks
instead of just be here be like
encyclopedia man for the universe but
i think people enjoy the passion that
you bring to
the answers of the questions okay you
know it's right i know your thing is to
empower people to find information on
their own or to steer them to
other information yeah i know that's
what you like that's an educator
but what i think people you don't want
to be the actual resource like you know
exactly like my mom used to say i was
like what's that mean go look it up
that's what she used to say mom what's
this word me i don't i don't be your
damn wikipedia
exactly but i think what people enjoy is
the fact that you bring the information
in a very entertaining and very
passionate fervent way okay so that's
what they really dig not just the
the fact that you're giving the
information all right all right so let's
do this
let's do and i haven't seen these
questions at all now you have not and
these are from
in the category no category so there's
the leftovers
little hodgepodge potpourri the
potpourri
okay that's right cosmic queries
potpourri and in math we would call it
random
right yes rather than poo-pourri
the random edition okay uh kasim
johnson wants to know this from facebook
and earth
because he doesn't tell me where on
earth he is from yeah if you don't say
we're just going to say your earth right
yeah all right
he says is it possible for a stable
black hole to exist
within a stable star
yeah that's kind of a wild question
uh no no
the black hole would eat the star oh
from the inside
out yeah oh my god that's amazing yeah
that'd be nasty that would be ugly ugly
totally ugly
oh it's it's like that uh the asian
uh drawing of a dragon eating itself no
or it's tail or it's tail
right yeah yeah so no there you have it
wow look at that man hey that's a
general uh image of a serpent so that
snakes would eat their tail too right
and because snakes don't have legs so
it's just a string eating itself
right it's a more it's a more clean
version of the image of that
right the but no but so that's eating it
from the
outside the black hole would eat it from
the inside nice yes
well there you have it good question and
by the way the center of a star is where
it's at it's hottest which is the source
of the generation of energy
so if your center became a black hole
you're not generating any
energy for the star anymore right and
that's all she wrote and that's it so
the star would just get sucked
right up yep yep okay nice nice
all right so thomas ballet wait wait now
you have to do
your imitation of the supermassive black
hole after just ate something
was that it no no that wasn't it okay
that's a middle school version of it
right right no no it was
the um the black hole
uh eating any star that comes nearby and
you say
[Music]
it was just a smell oh yeah it's a fat
black hole
oh that was delicious
i believe i just had a cosmic snack
it's a fat black hole i believe
yeah so black hole yeah it would eat the
star from there thank you for the
personification
i can't believe i just ate myself
all right thomas valenzuela
wants to know this thomas you gotta
admit that's a cool last name that is
valenzuela
you can't be you can't beat that yeah i
used to love that picture for the
dodgers yeah yeah
yeah all right so uh does the rotation
of the galaxies give
us north and south orientation in the
universe
based on something similar to the
uh coriolis effect and if that
is the case could it be used as a
reference to measure
distances and our position
versus the equator of the universe
no okay next question
no there's a there's some interesting
backstory here yes so
in physics we have an unambiguous way
of how to define what is north
really yes okay please so north has
meaning only in things that rotate
okay all right if i if i just put a book
in front of you say what's north
that means means nothing okay rotate
something now
take your right hand curl your fingers
in the direction the thing is rotating
okay then stick up your thumb mm-hmm
that's north
got you okay gotcha and so
that's how we can say if something is
rotating upside down right
relative to north because you'd have to
twist your hand upside down
curl it curl the fingers and now it's
rotating in that now your thumb is
pointing down
down okay so that's how we define
rotation
we did not know that the galaxy was a
rotating thing
until long after we had like named it
you know why is it called galaxy
galactose is greek for milk
that's the milky way going across the
knife it just looked like a streak of
white across the
street black and night sky not they
didn't think it was literally milk but
it was the
poetic reference to it right and so so
that's the galaxy
and now if you learn that it is a
flattened system
and then you want to ask does it have a
north and a south we
astronomers in the early day assigned
the north pole of the galaxy
to the pole of the galaxy that happened
to be in the northern hemisphere of the
earth
of earth's sky gotcha all right because
we're seeing it
from the north or top part of the top
part so our reference
we would later learn which way the
galaxy was rotating and it turns out
it's turning the other way
gotcha so we are stuck calling the north
pole of the galaxy
the opposite of what our laws that we
made for ourselves to define it as such
would give us gotcha yeah so in other
words the
the what we say is the south pole of the
galaxy
is in the north what we say is the north
pole of the galaxy
is in the northern hemisphere sky but
it's actually the south
galaxy yeah yeah so yes we can orient
the galaxy
but we the the universe we've never
found a way to orient it
there's no patch of material in one
direction or another an
axis a distribution a plane
right none of that this stuff is like
pretty random as far out as you go
that's cool man yeah so we could do that
here on earth because we have all of
those things
to measure and look at there's a north
pole of the solar system which ways all
are all the planets turning around the
sun because we see the sun as a center
which way is the sun rotating so that
sun has a north pole everybody's got a
north pole
gotcha yeah that is cool and that's
because we didn't know it was
we didn't know it was rotating we had to
discover the galaxy because we're in it
right very it's like how do you know
what your mother looks like if you're in
an embryo within her womb
that's so funny i don't know so one of
the last things we discovered was the
galaxy what
what the hell we look like in the galaxy
what a great uh
what a what a great example how do you
know what your mom looks like before
you're born yeah you have no idea right
you know her voice you get a selfie
stick and put it out
what i'm just that there could be a way
to do it that's awesome
oh my god selfie stick
it's almost 20 20 and everyone is
looking at everything on their cell
phones
you need your website to be perfect on
any mobile device
and wix automatically formats everything
from mobile
even lets you refine it for a perfect
experience
how cool is that head to the link in the
description and start your site today
that's wix.com go slash star talk
okay forget it okay let's move on to
alex perkins
alex is uh coming to us from earth and
alex says
um hey i just turned 30.
uh hey happy birthday man uh how
feasible is it in my lifetime to see
people land on
europa now i i suppose he's singing
using uh the average lifespan because we
don't know
alex could be hit by a bus next week you
know that's not
what what what
[Laughter]
i don't think that's the life expectancy
he's planning for this question okay
you're right
okay alex if you get hit by a bus next
week you ain't never seen this happen
all right uh so
so in the average lifespan now i'd like
to believe
that before alex turns 100 okay there's
the positive outlook yes
alex that we might be able to send
people to europa that would just be very
cool
that would happen only the day we are
like the solar system is our backyard
it that i don't see that as a
destination itself i see that as just
one of the many things we're doing in
space
right visiting europe and it'd be very
cool i i talk about going to europa all
the time
yeah go ice fishing on europa it's an
outer icy layer
layer of ice and stress from jupiter's
gravity
heats europa by the way europa and
jupiter outside of the goldilocks zone
right so if you're outside of it your
water is is
evaporated because you're too close or
you're frozen because you're too far
away
right jupiter pumps energy into europa
because of its gravity and has melted
the ice beneath the surface
so we got a it's like an eminem it's an
m
m moon it's got a hard candy outside
it's a hard credit
yes it's it's soft nice watery squishy
inside so you're out there
and i want to go like i said this many
times i want to go ice fishing on europa
there's a movie called the europa report
which is about the
man's first mission to europa and so and
they
and they want to look for life there so
yeah i think that could happen
definitely in his lifetime well with all
those oceans underneath europa
how likely is the uh the possibility of
life
because well water and life go together
hand in hand here on earth and i i've
said this before
uh there's life every place on earth
where there's water liquid water
even the dead sea correct now why is
there life in the dead sea
why is it called the dead sea because
they
okay there's no macroscopic fishes
swimming around but at the time they
named it the dead sea
you know what they didn't have no a
microscope
there you go so there you have it right
so they're defining their world by what
their senses tell them when in fact what
science is all about
is extending your senses and creating
new ways of detection that your
biological form can't even
approximate and then you deduce the
nature of the world
gotcha yeah sweet yeah all right great
question alex and uh i hope you live to
be a hundred buddy
okay all right james claver wants to
know
this uh he's from bangor michigan
he says i've been reading your book
death by black hole oh thank you
mm-hmm it's a fan favorite yeah by black
hole and you mentioned
that scientists knew there were holes in
the periodic table well before they were
discovered
i'm just wondering how did they know
maybe a brief history
of how they were originally organized so
we know these tables we know that
there's gaps how do they know there's
gaps
yeah so i i'd love me some periodic
table just i can't get enough periodic
table
just so you know so so so once you learn
how to organize the elements which is
what um
mendeleev figured out okay a russian
scientist
right uh he once you do that
if you arrange them by how many protons
are in their nucleus
very simple way to okay how many how
many protons you get
you got four then you're over here you
got five go next to four
you got seven skip one do we have six
yet no not well actually we did have six
six is carbon but
um you do have eight oh well that's
oxygen like give me a hard one
do you have nine right if and if no we
don't have yet but we got 10.
so 10 go in your 10 slot right well
who's where's nine we don't have it yet
we'll get get off your ass and find me
some nine and so
this these are how we you establish the
gaps in the periodic table the periodic
table is complete
from 1 up to 100 and what are we up to
110 or 12 or something
so it's not like you're going to just
discover some other element that's going
to price
right because there's no 9.7 there's no
9.7 correct
correct that's why it's complete that's
it yeah yeah
some some aspects of science are
complete just that's it
that's how it is that's why it's a
beautiful thing and it's a record of
discovery over the centuries
and i love it so for example the element
we we discovered an element on the sun
before we discovered it here on earth
okay and we named it after the sun
the sun god helios helium which became
helium
which is a lot of that in the sun oh
yeah it's like temp
about ten percent yeah helium yeah and
we're running out of it on earth
on earth that's right that's right and
so helium is not uncommon in the
universe
and because we keep feeling like
thanksgiving day balloons with
no actually in the old days they would
let it escape right and then regenerate
the helium but
and now they recapture it i've been told
because macy's is the
second biggest consumer of helium in the
world get out of here
after the u.s military and uh helium has
very special properties not all of which
i can divulge
get out really yeah come on yeah oh
like making you talk funny because
that's true the best not a secret not a
secret okay because that's the best one
by the way
all right great stuff man so there you
have it a periodic
so now that okay that's how you know you
have a missing element that's what we
say so
now now now go away let's take it one
step further go ahead there's an element
that was missing
and we did the calculation after quantum
physics was discovered
and we noticed that that element is
unstable so even if it was ever in the
universe it would have decayed into
something else by now
so it would be like a permanent gap
anything that was there was not there
now so we said well
okay let's just make it make the stuff
so we
manufactured an element to fit in the
gap
and we named it after ourselves we named
it after technology
it's called technetium technetium yeah
sweet yeah oh man and of course because
we made it it
can't last but we named it tech i mean
tech means
artificial yeah and in fact technetium
is is a very active
uh tool potent tool for the radiologist
because if you you can set it up in ways
that different half-lives
six hours or ten hours and you can do
experiments with
you know your your your circulatory
system uh
by tracking the radioactivity and if
small amounts are okay if it can
right and you can trace it as it moves
as it moves
the half-life it'll go away and then you
don't have to worry if you're done you
leave the hospital you're done right
yeah
that is brilliant i was once in a
hospital with one of my radiation
detectors which i occasionally carry
and only you would say someone someone
sat down next to me in the waiting room
and the alarm started going off
and i looked to the person i said okay
what are you in for
well they just did they just did a
radioactive dye test on it right and he
was still radioactive
as he would be for the next few hours so
i so i moved to another chair
wow all right um okay so we got yeah we
got one more
one more before we break all right this
is from rob z
what do you think the bright spot on
saris is
oh series series uh yeah so the the
largest asteroid
is actually has enough gravity to turn
it into a round shape so it's the only
round asteroid
technically we shouldn't even call it an
asteroid is it a what would a dwarf
planet then
precisely no oh i've been hanging around
youtube
oh i've been hanging around youtube so
objects that are
that are just big enough to be turned
into a sphere by their own gravity
right but they haven't cleared their
orbit because sirius is orbiting in the
asteroid belt
dwarf planet right pluto okay big enough
to be a sphere but it's orbiting in the
kuiper belt
dwarf planet there you go so a bright
spot on sirius i
i have no idea
i can tell you other stuff about series
it was the first asteroid discovered
back in 1800 or 1801 and
so obviously you're going to discover
the biggest brightest one first right
because that makes sense and so they
wanted to they thought they discovered a
planet
and so they went and planets are named
after roman gods god
and so they named it after um roman
roman goddess of harvest and
ceres that's the root of the word cereal
right
whole grain oats
that's a delicious planet or dwarf
planet so that's series
so i'm guessing it's a highly reflective
icy area
right of it of the object because ice
can be very reflective relative to any
other kind of rock
and it doesn't take much to be more
reflective than rock to show up
blazingly in images you take of an
object that's you so
that's my guess well there you go rob
get yourself a bowl and a spoon and
enjoy some
series so we uh we gotta take a break
chuck yes
when we come back more cosmic query's
potpourri edition
all that is random in the quizzical
universe
we're back on star talk tyson here chuck
points there that's right
yeah man we're popularing together yes
we are
and we're yes we are and we're smelling
good
um yeah we're pumpering together
potpourri
and asking me questions drawn from
our our loyal fan base yes
and you haven't asked me a really crazy
stupid question yet
and you know there's got to be some in
every batch oh good they're actually
very intelligent questions but some of
the weird ones get there are some
interesting answers to them i'm just
saying
yeah you're choosing i don't know
anything you you compiled this
all right look at this letting you know
since you said it uh
okay and maybe i'll change my mind after
this i don't know because guess what i
skipped over this question
in that first segment and as you saw me
just take pick this page back up yes you
picked that page back up that was in the
trash
i turned that over i'm gonna pick it
back up because here it is
oh it's from uh inti
armor to salt i know uh
a miter saw okay i'm not okay that's it
yeah
whatever you say
[Laughter]
you know what i think i think you
actually have no friends ever in your
life
so you never had any practice
pronouncing other people's names well
you got one part of that right
okay uh nt amateur
okay forget it if you had superpowers
would you wear spandex
okay so if you were a superhero would
you go with the spandex
uh if
maybe if i had a cut body and then the
spandex will show off the body
that could help intimidate criminals you
know right maybe
i'm just thinking i mean see i wouldn't
i would go with a three-piece suit
because then i'd show up and they think
i was just a banker and then all of a
sudden i'm like
blowing stuff up with my eyes throwing
guys across the room you want to be like
kingsman yes
with a dapper you know umbrella and uh
and a cane and every time i shout
they'll be like who is this guy
who is this banker that keeps showing up
and kicking our ass
yeah that's good i like the banker model
i like that yeah no you're right why
have spandex yeah no
no there's no uh you know and i think in
the early days superman was wearing
pantyhose you know so
pretty much yeah yeah blue pantyhose so
yeah there's no call for that
yeah you're right all right banker
three-piece suit three-piece suit all
right
sweet all right let me put that back
over you know what i would do
and i would draw from my supply of ties
and each tie would have a separate
different
superpower that it gave me now that's
kind of cool and if you saw my time
you you know you know how how i was
going to kick your ass that day
i like it stuff will get telegraphed
there we go okay all right there you go
so
thank you inti all right here we go
[Music]
uh this is from nelson saw nelson says
uh what are some of the most important
non-space-related advances
which came directly or mostly from
research
at nasa oh so of course nasa is fully
focused on space so
maybe the way to answer this is there
are advances that
directly helped space and things we were
doing in space and other things
that not only helped space but then
helped what we did here on earth
maybe that's the way to answer this
because nasa's not researching how to
make your better cup of coffee
but they do utilize technology and
technological advances
it is always with the mission of trying
to improve our
duration time technology and space
but that doesn't mean it can't apply to
very cool things on earth
for example go ahead something simple
you ready go ahead uh
lately if you have taken the exit ramp
over of most
highways and if that exit ramp has a
pretty tight turn
the pavement is grooved it is have you
noticed i have noticed that
okay that came from nasa and why exactly
would that come from nasa
because the last time i took space
there were no off ramps
i'm just curious okay as i understood
this when it was told to me
the uh you have the space shuttle coming
in for a landing
and it's not the space shuttle is a
glider coming in all right this back
when we actually put people in space how
sad
okay so but in the day way back
right as bill nye likes to do
he's always puts on his old man voice
way back in the day
you go back and when we flew space
shuttles when you come back to earth and
you're going to land you're landing a
glider
right right there's hardly any control
over your you know you have
heirloom flaps and things but you're a
glider now suppose it's raining or
there's
it's a little wet okay you don't want
the thing sliding to the left and the
right so you put grooves in the pavement
which help align the wheels in the
direction the wheel is rotating
which is the direction the road points
right
there you have it and so this reduced
the possibility of skidding
and people realize hey why don't we put
that on off ramps because
if you're going too fast and you come
off the ramp you're hitting the
embankment
right okay so now you can ask here's
here's the fascinating point
you can say why spend the millions of
dollars or whatever it took to a good
why not just have somebody invent that
right outright
why okay because
no one did however
cheap you think that is right the fact
is that solution
only came about when someone cared about
space
right and it turns out when you going i
have found you go into space
people gather around who care about that
right smart people
who care about that right and those are
the problems they want to solve
you're not going to go to the smartest
person in the room and say oh
can you help me prevent cars from
skidding off the off ramp of interstate
95. well see there's also
no money in that what you that last
point right
yeah hey help me stop cars from skidding
off like yeah well what's in it for me
right right and why should i help you do
that and i'm at the top of my class
why am i going to do that but if i
instead say prevent the space shuttle
after coming out of orbit from skidding
on its runway you're going to figure
this stuff out
right so space exploration has a way
of infusing levels and dimensions of
creativity
and anybody who thinks about it and
that's how you get these amazing
solutions to everyday life
oh man that is a great great point and
i'm not even calling them spin-offs
because the spin-off would be we got
this widget in space now you use the
widget on earth
it's not even about that no no yeah
these are i mean some of these are
direct
applications just because they as you as
as you see with the grooves you find use
for it somewhere else and it's extremely
important to have uh you can't think of
how many thousands of lives
probably have been saved by people
having groups that simple little thing
that's simple and no one writes a story
about the life
that was not taken so true yeah
i know which is why i often contemplate
suicide
chuck i'm joking i'm joking but it just
it was hanging there i had to say
medics hey well that was a great
question nelson
and uh just remember that uh nasa will
continue to uh
suffer budget cuts
i just figured i'd throw that in just
just say it wait wait
let me give you one more just one more
example okay so the docking
uh algorithms to get the space shuttle
to dock with the space station
right there are two sort of collars that
come together right and there's a laser
stabilizing system that enables that to
happen
right and there's software related to
that and the like i say right as in
i'm sure you're right i'm not saying
right as in yes you're correct
because i already knew that exactly so
so
what we found is that the surgery used
to cut your cornea have it re-healed to
adjust your vision
which would be correct lasik lasik
surgery uh
well we didn't always use lasers okay
a b so uh so now that it uses lasers
how do you do that to someone
if their eye might jiggle a little bit
while you're trying to cut
right because okay that's not what you
want that's not what you want two things
you want to jiggle eye and
so so what they've done was adapted
this laser stabilizing mechanism that
allowed the cut
to move with the moving eyeball in case
the moving eyeball moved
and it's from the docking mechanism of
the space shuttle in the space station
so so this nasa technology enabled
this laser lasik surgery to be conducted
safer and more cheaply than ever before
yeah that's why all of a sudden
everybody started getting it
absolutely it's because it's because it
came out of space
ah that's amazing not the concept for
the surgery no but just the
concept from the surgery came from an
accident that a guy had
and cut his eye no honestly he cut his
eye in the heel and he was like oh okay
i don't know why but i could see better
you know but
yeah i can imagine let me try it on you
exactly with the kitchen knife yeah i
can see better cause i cut my eye i
should try to cut your eye
i bet you i could heal you but uh that's
that's fantastic
so that's an example of
so two extremes of examples one where uh
vision has been improved the other your
driving has been improved
right and then both of them came out of
the space program yes
it happens all the time that's amazing
that's hey nelson great question man
great question all right um
here we go this is from scott and that's
all he says is this is from scott
i love it okay he says on your premiere
of cosmos you mentioned that the moon
was
pushed away by tidal friction
can you explain that a little bit
further i had never heard it put like
that
before yeah pushed is a very visual
image but what's really happening is
that it's getting flung
flung is a more sort of physically
accurate
thing right so what's going on is the
moon creates a tidal bulge
on earth and so it the water that's
nearest the moon
pulls towards the moon the moon is
pulling on earth a little less and the
water that's on the other side of the
moon is pulling on even
less so all the oceanic waters form this
bulge
that it's in a direct line to the moon
okay
okay all right it turns out it's not a
direct line to the moon
because earth is rotating and we're
rotating faster than the moon is turning
around it so we actually
drag this bulge ahead of the moon
okay okay okay so this bulge is actually
trying to slow us down
that's why we occasionally add leap
seconds to the calendar
gotcha and because the bulge is ahead of
the moon
right the moon feels a gravitational
force ahead of it
and so it wants to go faster in its
orbit
right and by going faster in its orbit
it ascends
to higher distances from earth gotcha
so it's a it's a it's a cosmic ballet
choreographed by the forces of gravity
gosh darn it that was fantastic so
the moon is spiraling away about five
inches a year from earth just because of
this
flinging effect right of the leading
edge of this tidal bulge
right oh mike that is fascinating
because it's like the earth is a
container holding this water yes
yes correct right so instead of lining
up
with the with the with the gravitational
pull from the moon right
because the earth is a container holding
this water
and it's spinning the water wants to
move ahead yeah
we're dragging the water ahead of the
water ahead of the moon and that costs
us our rotational energy to do so
that god
oh my god that's that's incredible
what it's just it's physics i know but i
you know i don't do that a lot no no no
i don't do physics a lot no no you you
know you look like a demo you look like
a double rainbow guy
you remember double rainbow guy he comes
around the corner of the mountain it's
on youtube right
right two rainbows
oh and he starts crying i say dude it's
physics okay
chill oh my gosh this is divine
no it's like it's light all right so so
i don't mean to take away the beauty of
this
by the way there are other things that
are mysteries that we don't understand
right that are even more beautiful but
i'm saying
like women we are in this tango
with the moon right ultimately if the
when the moon wins well it's not gonna
win
ultimately the moon wants to slow us
down so much
that we rotate at exactly the same rate
that the moon orbits us right and when
that's the case our tidal bulge will
align
we will not be fighting the bulge and
the bulge will not be flinging the moon
forward
and the system will be called will be in
what is called a double title lock
double title yeah which was a wrestling
sounds like i was gonna say i wanted to
invent
that move what i used to wrestle the
double title i wrestle and i know
astrophysics you know i was trying to
invent a double title lock
wrestling hold right yeah so so
what so what hap at that point earth's
day will equal
the lunar month and one side of the
earth will only ever face the moon
just as today one side of the moon only
ever faces the earth
which is why there's never earth rise on
the moon
right it's always in the sky if you're
on that half of the moon gotcha
yeah that's awesome which is why that
famous photo called earthrise taken by
apollo 8 in december 1968
it's called earthrise because the earth
was rising over the moon why well it's
because they were orbiting
right they're orbiting the moon exactly
they pull up the camera and there's
earth rising
that's how you get earth rise but people
thought oh earth rises on the moon just
like the moon rises on earth
not now right that's amazing not until
the moon
wins unfortunately i'm still stuck on
double title lock and i'm trying to
figure out
like do you put your like legs around
the person's neck and then you're like
hanging off of their back
and then you grab both their knees and
then you like whip it and you know i got
no i i
i'll show you off camera i'll show you
i never perfected it but i had i had the
ideas of one it was good
that's pretty cool all right that was
what happens is you face your opponent
and then
i swing you until you're out of balance
and then take you down while i'm still
facing you
because in a double title lock both
sides of the orbs are facing one another
no matter what they do so the idea is to
get the person still facing you
and then as i swing them down right
yeah yeah that's fantastic maybe get a
quick one in before the break all right
okay
let's get a quick one quick one quick
one
all right here's a good one man yeah
will this guy look different
if we are all standing on another planet
constellations and such so if i'm if i'm
on another planet in this
solar system do i see the same sky yes
what you heard what i said you said yes
yeah so here's it's a simple answer okay
so the extent of our solar system is
like from
like the sun to neptune
get over it no if you look at the
planets so
so it says so basically we're such a
small
exactly right exactly so you're not
gonna change the frame of reference
exactly so if you look at the width of
the solar system it's like 10
light hours across okay it would take a
beam of light
10 hours to cross the solar system
that's big
that's a long time especially going to
speed of light right
however as you look at the nearest stars
the stars that comprise the
constellations
they are hundreds of light years away
gotcha
so if you just shift your head 10 light
hours you know the stars don't get
nothing
they don't mean a damn thing that that's
ours so you got to start moving among
the stars
to change your perspective on the
constellations for them to take on other
shapes
and drag all the astrologers with you as
they try to keep up with the new shapes
right okay and tell you how the universe
will now affect you right
because of the random stars oriented in
the galaxy that one looks like someone
looking at a cloud what will we call it
that's it jack we got to take a break uh
we'll come back and continue
you got more questions yes i do when
star talk continues more
from cosmic queries
chuck we're back yes and this is cosmic
queries
uh star talk radio cosmic rays edition
and this in this our final segment we're
going to save the last several minutes
for
the lightning round yeah i don't know if
we'll get through all the questions but
then we get through like a whole
boatload in a short amount of time
exactly so let's let's work up to that
with some continued uh
questions and with my fully fleshed out
answers all right all righty any more
weird questions i mean weird questions
have sometimes interesting answers
this is true um what do you got okay
okay
uh here's one from jonathan smith from
las vegas nevada and you can pronounce
his name
you know what that's so true i'm gonna
give you a little gold star each time
yeah well you know i i don't think i can
really uh
be proud of jonathan smith
is that the dude who who messed with
pocahontas jonathan yeah was it jonathan
john smith
yeah i thought that yeah i think it is
but who's the guy who founded the
the mormons oh
john uh i'm getting my people mixed up i
forgot his yeah
yeah okay but john smith definitely
pocahontas yes
neil yeah i've heard that the strongest
evidence for gravity waves
is the spiraling together of two neutron
stars as
the ripples yes yes okay
however neutron stars have incredibly
strong magnetic pull as well
indeed is it possible that the same
dynamo
effect that causes our sun to
slow its rotation could be causing
neutron stars
to lose their combined angular momentum
over time
no oh okay i'll tell you why go ahead
because
we can look at the ripples that neutron
stars
send out as they as they draw near one
another
and you calculate using einstein's
general theory of relativity
at what rate would it lose orbital
energy to gravitational waves
okay and you write down that number and
then you look we have binary neutron
stars in our galaxy
and they are losing energy at exactly
that rate there's no unaccounted for
need to then say here's some other
mechanism that's not even necessary
it works exactly we know where the
energy is we know where it came from and
where it's
going yeah exactly so but great question
that is very and it's how you
how you make these deductions in the
universe you look at something you know
very well
if it accounts for everything there's no
need to keep you could keep looking but
why
i mean right yeah i mean maybe it's
sharing the cause but
everything i know about how i've
accounted for it works
right so there's no need to you're done
and move on to the next part that ain't
broke don't fix it exactly there you go
all right so jesse from vancouver canada
would like to know this
um given that there is an upper limit
or upper speed limit to the universe
being the speed of light
and a lower speed it's not just a good
idea it's the law
[Laughter]
buckle up galaxy exactly
you never know okay um
and there's a lower speed limit oh by
the way the buckling up
uh you only buckle up because the car
your car
changes speed right not because it
exists at any one speed at all
well it's the change that's pretty
change is what will kill you yeah right
that's why
you can be in an airplane going 600
miles an hour at 39 000 feet and they
say
you may now unbuckle your seatbelt right
because nothing's going to happen right
if you maintain your speed that's not a
problem yes if your speed changes
and that's what your seat belt is for
and i just love that they put seat belts
on airplanes as well
not i i get it for the turbulence but
for the crash
really really do you really think that
seat belts you're about to crash buckle
your seat buckle up
okay no i'm not my favorite one is like
you know if you don't uh bring your seat
back up the four inches
you're going to die right the crash
what's that you're the only one who dies
okay so given there's a lower speed
limit which is the absolute zero
temperature
could velocity be considered a dimension
like space length width and depth
uh you have to ask where where are you
going to go with that what are you going
to do with that
because for example you can have a speed
and then i can slow you down with breaks
right did you change dimension i mean
where are you getting with that
why what is the purpose of even having
half thinking about it that way right if
you wanna by the way creative thinking
is
highly a good thing in this world okay
but
if you do so ask yourself is there
something you will now be able to
explain
that you couldn't before that's it
because everything we've constructed
about velocity and speed and all this
it's as einstein said uh or was it uh
his protege
uh said space tells matter how to move
and matter tells space how to curve wow
yeah it's deep
that's a great one yeah it's good it's
deep so um in that sense it's not your
speed but
it's the gravity that's creating the
dimensionality of the fabric of space
you can move within that so we move
within the fabric of space
so the velocity itself is not there's no
cause to think about it that way that's
right
so i applaud the exercise yeah yeah
exactly it's very creative thinking and
your answer jessie is
dark matter i'm just saying
one question with something else we
don't know anything about right see
that's how i do it no people do
yeah people say oh can we explain this
thing in terms of consciousness
we don't know what consciousness is so
just back up right right give it space
that's funny but see you know what
that's a that's a great little cheat
though it is a cheat
it's a great series it's a complete
sheet yeah people do it all the time
yeah it makes
i mean listen cause i i don't know about
this well why don't we think about it in
terms of something else we don't know
about exactly that'll answer
because that'll answer it right that's
very funny right
all right this is from amanda milligan
and she says
in every document where's she from she's
from earth she is from earth okay
she's just from earth uh in every
documentary i have seen lately
extraterrestrial life
is animal how do you think plant life
would evolve outside of our own world or
could there be
life that exists that could not be
classified
as either plant nor animal it's still
life
there's a famous science fiction story
and forgive me for i forgot who wrote it
because i i don't come in here with
notes
and anticipation you don't know these
questions so how could you right right
so
so there's a science fiction story where
the aliens came upon earth
and saw that we there's like muscle
tissue
and they go back to their home planet
and says they're made of
meat
because the aliens are made of some
spirit energy right
right and we're made of meat right and
another thing that we take for granted
but i can imagine an alien
uh life form that would just freak out
other than salt other than salt
animals have to kill to consume
food other than the consumption of salt
everything else you eat
was once alive okay sorry sorry unless
you
live off of milk and honey all right
those themselves are not going to
cannibal
animals that's an animal byproduct you
have to kill something i don't and even
the vegetarians
taste it was alive slaughtering carrots
that's right all right yeah
and slicing them dicing them up and
shredding them
yes so the fact that we have to kill
other life forms on our own planet for
our own sustenance
could easily be seen as one of the most
barbaric things
to another civilization where they all
absorb
energy from their host star right
yes there you have it because they're
absorbing and not consuming well they're
and and
they're limited they're not ingesting
their unlimited source of energy from
their sun
uh just like planets by plants on earth
right they don't have to eat anything
there's some that do of course but most
nearly all other planets don't the venus
fly trap is carnivorous and what's the
other one that eats flies that
smells like picture plant there's one
that that uh oh you're talking about the
one that
it smells like rotting yeah yeah rotting
flesh yeah so that one okay so they're
carnivorous but all the rest of picture
plants are doing just fine with sunlight
yeah and that's that's an awesome way to
live i think
if i were to evolve the human into
another form i'd involve us with solar
panels on our skin
nice our skin would be one big solar
panel and that way you're getting
sunburned you just
recharge your your energetics yes i
believe they call that
africans i'm just saying
last i heard that's why they're black
yep i say
i just said that's why they're black
that's so crazy
all right megan morrissey says hi
i'm showing for the first time an
episode of cosmos in my
high school earth sciences class give it
up for the teachers of the world there
you go
one of my students just asked me if a
ship that is designed
like a ship of imagination would
actually be able to fly into space
would that be possible love your show
and thank you i'm not authorized to say
whether i actually own one of these
all right now the the ship of the
imagination on purpose
has mobility through space and time and
that mobility
is empowered by my thoughts whoa so
there are no controls there's no
uh plus we had a mini discussion with
with andriyan
who specified in the script that the
ship would be impossibly
minimalist right so i would not be
wearing a badge
which would imply that i'm captain and
you're not right because you should be
able to fly this as well
so so the ship no it exists completely
in my imagination as your tour guide so
no there is no attempt to try to make it
real
there you go as there have been with the
starship enterprise and other
sort of sci-fi creations so yeah it's
not uh it's not real or it can even be
imagined to be real
right because it exists in my mind nice
as you're a private tour guide there you
go
yeah there you go okay uh you know what
time it is uh-oh it is
i'm so bad at hitting this belt damn
there we go around lightning round okay
oh my god we got a lightning round okay
so
i'm answering in sound bites because you
still have so many i didn't get to okay
right ready go okay here we go
um jehovah
wants to know as the sun expands and
gets closer to the earth
will the what will happen to the earth
besides getting really hot
oh so the well well uh the
the story here is that it's getting hot
okay that's the story all right so the
gravity will be the same
we'll still orbit the sun in the same
amount of time but it's as it gets hot
the oceans will come to a rolling boil
and evaporate into the atmosphere the
upper
atmosphere will itself evaporate into
space
as we become engulfed by the expanding
sun and we become
a vaporized ember orbiting deep within
earth's surface
boom have a nice day
[Laughter]
from andrew lownsberry who says this is
not relevant to science
but where did neil get his celestial
vest oh
actually i own about six vests okay and
they're for different stages of how
wide my belly is at different times
but the one i most the one i'm most seen
in it was the last vest
sold at the gift shop of the hanson
planetarium
in utah in salt lake city utah before
that closed and reopened
in another identity and in fact they had
no more left and i bought it off the
back of the salesperson
and i've yet to see anyone else wearing
this vest
ever again damn so yeah that's the one
that that person is probably so pissed
off took it off their back
but they agreed i didn't take i didn't
steal it off there man give me the best
you know who i am i'm ndt no
i'm sorry okay next and next we're
lightning round next
okay uh martikeo
thank you says mars
pioneers will be the first true 100
renewable
will the mars pioneers be the first true
100 renewable energy human community
ever uh that's the that's the plan the
mars one plan is
yes yes yes that's the plan okay
initially they'll get supplies you know
supply chain from earth but ultimately
they start making the stuff themselves
thank you mark from argentina next
all right adam hello
oh you son of a gun hal lavaca says
hello i'm writing from slovakia and me
and my friends would like to know what
does neil think about
pirating illegally downloading
or torrenting the show cosmos
okay what do i think of it because
clearly they're doing that
apparently get his ip address right now
um i don't know how much control there
is over that and
my guess is more people pirate it than
who would ever even buy it in the first
place
so that the exposure is greater than it
would otherwise be
um i you know if everyone pirated
there'd be no money to actually produce
the product
right so what i would say is for people
who are pirating if you're doing so
let it be because you actually can't
afford it right right and and then
there's a way
i'd rather you knew this then you didn't
right but the minute you have cash flow
then you know pay that forward right
dude right
you know now you're screwing it up for
everybody yeah so i don't
i can't endorse illegal behavior but um
if you can't afford it and you want
to learn it's like abby hoffman wrote a
book called steal this book
right steal that book right that he
wrote which was a way if you were
without means to try to
uh you know sort of exploit the system
there you go until you didn't have to
so yeah no i i don't if someone told me
they pirated it
and then they came and they came to one
of my lectures and
and bought something else later on fine
it's an investment okay
there you go so the answer is go ahead
and steal them
[Laughter]
no that was not a sound bite answer i'm
supposed to give a sound bite answer ah
i'll give it one more and we'll sound
bite that and we're done okay so we're
way over okay okay
one more go here we go uh
with iron and low gravity would mars be
an ideal place to build
larger interstellar rocket ships and
space stations
yes if you if you build a ship and you
can launch from a low gravity place
that's what you want to do because half
of your launch energy
leaving earth is just to get the hell
off of earth
into orbit right the other half energy
can take you practically anywhere else
in the universe
certainly in the solar system so so yes
launch from the lightest place you
possibly can
and you know what that is it might be
empty space itself whoa
there you go chuck we're out of time yes
that was uh popular edition
of star talk cosmic queer yes it was all
right chuck i'll look for you on tv on
true tv
yes and you always make me laugh thanks
for being a part of the star talk family
it's a pleasure uh you've been listening
to star trek radio neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and i
have always
before we go i just want to thank wix
from simple landing pages to complex
professional websites
wix has you covered no need to hire a
web developer
if i was able to build this for star
talk certainly you can build your site
with wix
the editor gives you full design freedom
freedom
it's like that that was my brave hard
wix thing oh never mind they have apps
that let you grow your business
they have unlimited funds everything
just works
it's like magic no it's like science
head to the link in the description and
start your site today that's
wix.com go slash star talk
you